are you off the documentary matter
because it's been a while since you've
talked about a documentary a lot of them
have been very underwhelming I watched
I've watched a few I watched one
recently which one about Woodstock 99 I
watched that one yeah that one was
awesome that was pretty good actually
yeah that one was pretty pretty such a
[ __ ] show I like now now I like it right
if I see a documentary that's over four
parts I'm like you better have something
yeah very very good yeah because you
have no right to drag it out to like 10
hours like there's just so many
documentaries where they spend so much
[ __ ] time just interviewing people
who have no [ __ ] say they're just
like yeah I was scared that day too cuts
and it's just like
I don't care tell me where what happened
yeah that's I think that's why I've just
not watched a lot of documentaries
recently just because so many [ __ ] yeah
because I remember on the Japan trip we
all watched the Jimmy Savile documentary
yeah that was the hype thing that uh
that came out what do you mean hi why
are you saying it like that well it was
like it was hard because because Connor
and Chris were just like yo you know
Chris had been hyping it up a lot
because of course you know it's like
very very British it's a very notable
thing in British history yeah yeah so we
were like and I didn't know about it so
you guys were excited for me to discover
this [ __ ] thing because there'd be no
really documentaries about this dude um
if you want to know briefly it's very
disgusting there's this very very very
very famous British presenter who turned
out to be a pedophile and was doing it
for years and everyone knew and never
did anything yeah and yeah it turned
into this whole thing and no one to make
a documentary about it it's pretty much
like a big big shame Point yeah yeah
television
um but yeah there's a documentary coming
out about it there's two Arts we thought
oh great maybe it'll be like really
condensed really talking about it it
wasn't that good it wasn't and then like
here's the other thing
before it came out all the all the news
journalists like it's too graphic to
show you can't show anything it's
disgusting you can't play it on the air
it's it shouldn't air and then you watch
it and it was honestly it didn't really
account any of the horrible stuff he did
it really just like I definitely like
yeah because I remember I saw that and I
was like oh I'm gonna expect to be like
yeah sick afterwards and I'm like I fish
and I was like the Epstein documentary
is way worse yeah they barely spoke
about the horrible shooting they really
glossed over it and we're like it was
like more about building him up and then
they glossed over the fact that he did
like I mean they mentioned it and they
had some interviews from people but yeah
they really didn't mention much and it
was like this guy was like that it was
like the second half of the second
episode yeah yeah so that was that was
kind of meh and then there was this
other one I watched was about like a
power plant in New York that like
malfunctioned a nuclear one yeah and it
was just too long it was so [ __ ] long
yeah there was no need to for it to be
as long as it was right and the reason
why is because they just kept padding it
out with interviews from people who who
just lived in the area and it was like
okay I understand you've got all these
people you do not need I do not need
nine residence interviews that's just
like that's too many yeah too many yeah
yeah like for me I only really like
documentaries nowadays if it's like one
movie or something yeah or just like a
single Woodstock the Woodstock one was
good because it's only three episodes
and it's each one is themed and it's
pretty freaking condensed 97 right 99
yeah it's very good yeah I think like
one of my favorite documentaries of all
time was one about some triplets yeah
yeah yeah that's great that was great
like separated at Birth yes yes I can't
remember what it's called but it's it's
like it's a documentary where they
present you this story of these triplets
that got separated at Birth and then
they by complete chance like reconnect
with each other like I think what
happens at the beginning is that one of
the uh one of the triplets goes into
like a school that the that his brother
went to and everyone thought that he was
his brother and he was like what are you
talking about I don't I don't have a
brother I've not been here and so they
meet and they reconnect and they then it
was such big news that they got
broadcasted on TV and when they got
broadcast on TV if they if it was found
that another brother saw his [ __ ]
mirrors on TV he's just like me for real
and then his Mumford he and then
obviously they contact the parents and
I'm like uh I think there's another one
I think I'm your long lost number one I
think I'm your long-lost twin and it's
it's such an incredible story because he
sets up really cool sets up this really
cool story and then it goes deeper and
it's almost like Hollywood level it's
very good it's it's it's so such a good
story that this could be just a film and
if it was a film people would be like
this is too unrealistic
I watched
um what kind of recently and things like
why I shot my dad why I shot my dad yeah
some it's about a it's three episodes uh
the title's self-explanatory hours yeah
it's literally yeah you know it's just
wise guy killed his dad right uh you
should watch it it's pretty interesting
um it's one of the better jobs I think
Netflix is on the documentaries it was
pretty concise like like True Crime
documentary style yeah it was it was
like it was it was good it was
interesting
um and I found that it like I don't want
to spoil it what are you gonna say Kai
so I was just gonna say that it's called
three identical strange yeah
watch that one of the best documentaries
I've ever seen I watched the Our Father
one I've watched a lot I've just haven't
talked Our Father Our Father about the
doctor the sperm Doctor Who is injecting
his own oh yes
[ __ ] gross your watch
and they all found each other eventually
and started finding each other through
like and only started fighting each
other through like uh like DNA tests
what I mean uh 23andMe yeah yeah and
then it's really [ __ ] it's a
disgusting documentary that one was way
more disgusting than the Jimmy uh the
the [ __ ] yeah
uh it was it was an okay one I thought
it was okay I thought it was I don't
know I I it's weird for me I didn't
really enjoy it that much yeah but I
don't know I just feel like since the
Tiger King hype died down I feel like
people I remember people were used to
completely forgotten yeah yeah right
because I remember that Tiger King
dropped and everyone's like we got to
watch every documentary I think that
that has set the bar almost too crazy
yeah because crazy [ __ ] like that just
doesn't happen yeah it just doesn't so
now like you'll hear like this guy
killed five people and got away with it
and you're like
wake me up so interesting here yeah just
what like this is some crazy [ __ ] yeah I
watched a bunch of ones I've watched
like ones about like neighbors from hell
and that was [ __ ] it was boring
I want a documentary or is that just a
[ __ ] Gordon Ramsay yeah and it was
all about neighbors who'd killed their
neighbor
yeah it sounds like a YouTube series
yeah and it was I think I think that's
an actual TV series on ITV with no
killing of we know now we know there was
another one where it was like I forgot
what it was called [ __ ] it was kind of
good actually it was was one where this
dude owned a hotel yeah and he was he
had built uh he owned a motel in America
yeah and he had built uh uh in the roof
he had built like walkways to each room
and then instead of actually having
vents they were like fake Vents and he
would watch what they were doing oh and
he was peeping on them that's creepy
yeah it's disgusting is it a good
documentary yeah yeah it's really
[ __ ] interesting okay because it's
like the guy who actually was doing it
it's a crime by the way what he's doing
but yeah obviously um the guy actually
did it uh now because he'd stopped doing
it about 20 years ago a statue of
limitations had passed right so you
can't be charged for doing any of the
stuff oh [ __ ] and he had wrote down all
these uh all the other things about
um and it follows the the main point is
that a journalist is is getting him to
talk about it yeah so you're following
it through kind of the journalist eye
and this guy is a little unreliable with
his stories but he's doing it and it's
really interesting and he talks about
how he used to watch people have sex and
that's how he got off the Voya that's it
because he's a Voya and he used to get
off to people used to get off to people
having sex
mother knows breast and the Voya
honestly it's it's a really interesting
watch because it's like you know it's
rare you get to see people who do [ __ ]
up [ __ ] like this openly talk about it
yeah it's gross though but it's it is
interesting I was one of the more
interesting ones I found I don't know
why am I am I just annoy me for thinking
that my favorite documentaries are just
like the Nature Documentaries no no no
that's a different category in my mind
right right like I feel like people and
animals are different subjects yes
because uh because there's this because
this is nature documentary that I saw
and I forgot the name of it but they
used this like it was like the first of
its kind I don't know if it actually is
that's what they said in the show but
they use this like new camera technology
where they could shoot things in the
dark and they could pump up the exposure
that was it must have been on um [ __ ]
what's the BBC One the Earth
they had the scenes where the Scorpions
were fighting like the bats in the sand
yeah no no there was another one where
it was just about these like special
night vision cameras it's a reason oh
okay okay planet Earth had the night
vision yeah yeah yeah oh yeah we're in
the sand and that was [ __ ] yeah like
where it's like infrared right and you
can like see them yeah no it's not
infrared no it was black and white oh no
no it wasn't even black and white like
these are cameras where like if you
didn't if you didn't know that this was
shot at night you would think it was
shot during the day uh-huh like it's
like so bright it's this new type of
like infrared camera technology where
everything just becomes clear so they
they get these like amazing shots of all
of these like nocturnal Wildlife that
are just like in the African Savannah
pitch black but with through the camera
you can see it like it's daytime oh
that's [ __ ] yeah and it looks really
[ __ ] cool I wish I could remember
that yeah we are like the worst
recommenders it's a show about it
I don't [ __ ] know the name I think
one of my favorite shots in just all of
documentaries in like planet Earth 2 or
something yeah
um
so [ __ ] good but there's even even
with the amazing shots that they got in
that uh do you remember the one scene
where there's this lizard and then it
gets surrounded by a bunch of snakes and
it's a [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] Heist
movie or some [ __ ] right where the
lizard has yes the lizard [ __ ] likes
it yes and he climbs up
and then all the snakes like start to
like gather around him and then like
he's [ __ ] dodging things left and
right like he's a [ __ ] rugby player
or something this is a big meme back in
the day yeah I want to add this was a
big meme yeah and then like one of the
snakes like got like got a hold of him
you're like [ __ ] man it's story over
okay I remember it's called night on
Earth yeah yeah yeah but like some of
these some of these scenes like
like look at that like that doesn't down
okay it's like actually bright oh that's
[ __ ] yeah it's really cool it's on
Netflix check it out yeah check it out
what's planet Earth is also amazing that
must be like one of the like imagine
being the cameraman and just getting
this shot and just being like
[ __ ] I don't want to know how long it
took them to God oh my God like those
shots of like the the the time lapse of
like the plants growing and [ __ ]
the planet Earth shots some of them I'm
like how yeah how did you do this I
don't get it yeah it's incredible those
those are the Real G's because like
that's they ah they must be out there
for like [ __ ] months man oh yeah yeah
just to get one shot let's get one
[ __ ] shot yeah and be like yeah I've
been drawing planet Earth in like one
day
yeah I'm sure there are situations where
they get the shop day one yeah all the
times where they spent months trying to
get shot yeah or where they never give
them it's like a dude perfect video
I remember growing up though like some
of my favorite things to watch on like
late night too I don't know how it was
like in the UK but in Australia like
after around like 11 p.m 12 a.m it would
just be like either really really quiet
Nature Documentaries that would just go
on for way too [ __ ] long nothing
played after 12. oh really
um maybe one one or two was the cut off
right when yeah nothing started playing
yeah really it would it would either be
for us it would either be maybe it was
just like the the Australian free free
air TV but it was like it was either
Nature Documentaries or it was like old
black and white European films huh that
had English subtitles on it you know a
lot of a lot of the TV networks in the
UK after midnight would just turn into
like static casinos
what yeah remember this I remember it
was I don't know if I'm completely
making this up well but was there a
point where it just turned into teletext
it's just uh
I don't even how do you even describe
Teletubbies it's kind of like a catalog
of [ __ ] I guess like they used to turn
into these like yeah like TV shopping or
not even as it would display a bunch of
information and I don't even know I
don't so it's just like pop-ups like I
can't remember which networks did it but
they would literally turn into like text
now and you could text like 10 pounds to
put on black and they would spin over
that wheel I'm not I'm not kidding what
yeah they would do this this is teletext
right questions that looks scary yeah
Telly takes this oh yeah that was on BBC
that was on that was on BBC wait it
would just like display the news or some
[ __ ] like that it looks that looks like
a really [ __ ] Commodore 64 game it does
doesn't it I can't be yeah a lot of them
did it or you could just you know a lot
of them was there's like buying channels
stuff we can buy stuff yeah yeah no we
had we had stuff like that as well but
yeah generally after like three nothing
would play until six yeah I feel like
Australia would have got a lot of Nature
Documentaries because I mean Australia
is one big nature document maybe it
wasn't a nature documentary maybe it was
just some guy live streaming like a
camera outside of his room got a little
Joy here he was like oh [ __ ] what's that
oh never mind yeah no no we used to have
I remember specifically on SBS which is
channel three we used to have after like
11 they were just for on up until maybe
about five six a.m they would just play
all of these really old like 40s and 50s
European films that were like spoken in
like Italian and Spanish and German and
stuff like that with English subtitles
and they would just keep playing those
that's cool yeah and I'm like but like
you it was always you would flick on the
TV and you would just be in the middle
of this random movie and just like I
don't know what the [ __ ] is happening I
love watching movies on TV because it
turns Lord of the Rings into like three
hours into five because all the [ __ ]
ads
but uh yeah yeah I mean like I don't
even like because when I was in
Australia even when I was staying in
Australia I swear there was they played
a nature documentary when I was just
staying at my cousin's house and I'm now
that you're saying that I'm like how
damn how much it was how much of
Australian TV was just Nature
Documentaries dude Australians love
nature documentary that was just like I
was yeah when I was staying in Australia
it was this it was the weirdest [ __ ]
nature documentary as well right why let
me let me describe this nature
documentary that I saw I bet it's not
gonna be that weird no because it's just
such a niche topic right okay okay let
me say it's it's the how it is what it
is it was like a symphony so it started
off like with going to like
a band and they were like playing some
classical music and it was a symphony
about rivers
and oh he's trying to make one
and it wasn't it wasn't just because I I
saw it I saw like because I was flicking
through channels and I was looking at
the description of this Symphony for
Rivers I have no [ __ ] music yeah so
it was like music right I know and it
was just like the description was like
here's a documentary uh that is about
how Rivers have basically
um have basically shaped Humanity the
history of like the human races okay and
I was like cool I get to learn about
river river civilizations and all that
stuff but it was just like like
Mesopotamia yeah yeah yeah none of that
[ __ ] all right it was it was just it was
basically a music video yo with rivers
in there and I was like what is this I
don't understand this wait wait so
there's no narration there was like you
know there was like
there's like the most Bare Bones basic
narration where it was just like one
Epic voice being like Rivers have been
around since the beginning of humanity
and then it's just like okay
yeah where the river's good I mean I
mean they were good well the shot's Epic
no no the shots the cinematography was
out of this [ __ ] world but man it was
that was it that was it it was it felt
like someone was just like damn I got
some pretty cool [ __ ] drone shots no
idea what the [ __ ] to do with it there's
leftover drone shots
and they're just like let's put a
[ __ ] Symphony behind it what was the
most hype River what was the most hype
River
I don't know they didn't even say the
name of the rivers it was just random
shots oh different Rivers it's just
rivers from all over the world River
just to show you how cool the rivers are
documentary Symphony I need to find the
name I need to see this
is it
is it just called Rivers
it's like a movie title Rivers oh yeah
here we go River Dolph wood uh dog wolf
dog wolf documentary a cinematic and
musical Odyssey that explores the
remarkable relationship between humans
and rivers this is it this is it this is
this is the exact [ __ ] wait dog wolf
sounds really familiar I feel like they
did something really famous yes it's on
the Australian chamber orchestra Channel
how do you not know this is your culture
I [ __ ] know I'd know if we had a an
orchestra Channel
oh no oh dogwoofer found that they're a
London company actually
dog wolf is a film Distribution Company
based in the United Kingdom don't blame
us that's you guys make you're the one
who [ __ ] took the rivers and added on
TV you never know he's like actually
hold on the rivers have a point yeah
we have a lot of beautiful rivers in
Australia this is the most you've ever
said River on the podcast
River Phoenix